on va s'intéresser à présent au commerce
de proximité et oui car ses habitants
habituellement à cette période de
l'année un que les commerçants
organisent des événements pour
promouvoir un petit peu leur statut et
augmenter leur visibilité comme à
voisins le bretonneux où une quarantaine
de commerçants distribuer un carnet de
réduction pour la deuxième année
consécutive
trente mille carnets ont été éditées et
puis distribué dans les boîtes aux
lettres principalement objectif
fidéliser la clientèle et pro est prouvé
que la cohabitation avec les grandes
enseignes est possible explication avec
la présidente de l'association
on est tous des commerces de proximité
on a une clientèle qui est quand même
une clientèle vie sinoise et des proches
alentours qui nous est quand même
relativement fidèle donc c'est aussi un
geste de fidélisation de remerciement à
venir fréquenter régulièrement nos
commerces je pense qu'on peut dire
quelque part que tout le monde s'y
retrouve en fait que le commerçant oui
bon bah il fait un effort mais il y aura
un petit peu plus de fréquentation sur
un laps de temps est un autre côté bas
nos clients je pense qu'ils sont
contents de trouver un peu ce genre
d'offre cette année par exemple nous
avons franck provost qui fait trois
offres sur son salon de coiffure
trois offres différentes
nous avons également notre bouche et le
fin gourmet qui fait deux offres
différentes nous avons notre opticiens
qui de champ fleuri qui lui aussi fait
trois offres différentes
ceux qui participent ont justement aussi
une petite affiche avec la magie du
chéquier il ya des offres sur tous les
quartiers de boisin aussi bien
centre-village la grande île la
bretonnière
champfleury bien sûr on peut très bien
faire bon ménage comme c'est le cas sur
voisins je pense puisque de toute façon
carrefour market est une une enseigne
qui fait partie des trop trop grosses
enseignes qui qui va être un moteur de
toute façon pour le centre village et
puis
on va nous avoir à côté des offres
complémentaires a finalement ce que
apporte donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu 7
ce partenariat ou carrefour market n'a
pas hésité du tout à nous le nous
distribuer les chéquiers en caisse et
cette offre est valable jusqu'au 18
novembre à noter également la couenne
hier la fête du commerce de proximité du
6 au 21 octobre avec l'opération
coignières à tout prix